هو حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
عبر الهاتف تركي ال الشيخ رئيس هيئه
الترفيه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه اهلا
بك معالي المستشار يعني ماذا ستفعلون امام
هذا الطلب الكبير والمتزايد على تذاكر
المباراه العدد وصل الى الان حتى مليونير
طلب
مساء الخير عليكم
استاد الملك فهد
دره الملاعب في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
انا اهتم فيها هذا المباراه
يعني
هذا دلل على شيء على
ان هذه النتائج نقطه من من من محيط وليس
بحر محيط نتائج رؤيه
سيدي همم رئيس مجلس الوزراء ولي العهد
الرؤيه همم الحمد لله رب العالمين اقبال
غير طبيعي غير مسبوق همم يعني انا في
تليفونات همم
مباشره ومتواصله تستمعي نتيجه الظهر غير
مسبوق
كان في تاخير في السيستم تعليق طلب من
اكثر من 170 دوله حول العالم
تجاوزنا 2 مليون طلب وقفنا لما اعلنا
تذاكر نهضه وقفنا عند هذا الرقم لو
استمرينا لا استمر هذا الرقم كان بيني
وبين اخويا همم
ناصر الخليفه همم
رئيس نادي بعدين بعدين
تكررت هذه المباراه بالضبط
[موسيقى]
لمولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين حافظ الله
الرؤيه
اي والله ثم ادعمهم ما وصلني مثل هذه
الاحداث التاريخيه التي تحصل في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
لقاء تاريخي لقاء سيكون محطه مظاهر العالم
فيه عاصمه
واحده من اهم عواصم العالم همم الرياض
الحمد لله والشكر ولكن قلت اقول لكم انا
في احراج انا فعلا بلا مبالغه همم جميع
هواتمي تم اغلاقه انا ما همم نتعرف احراج
كبير همم
رساله واتساب
ما استطيع ان اتعامل مع الجميع
لكن ان شاء الله يتم الحدث ان شاء الله
بشكل يكفيهم وان شاء الله يليق بموسم
الرياض باذن الله مع المستشار ما حدث كما
قلت حضرتك رقم قياسي لم يحدث في بطولات
كبرى اضافه الى الانجازات والارقام
القياسيه التي تم تحقيقها في موسم الرياض
هذا يسعدنا جميعا بدون شك ولكن يزيد من
التحديات من الصعوبات التي يمكن ان
تواجهكم في المواسم المقبله
صحيح
كل صعوبات لها حل ايه
بقياده
مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين وتسموا سيدي
رئيس مجلس الوزراء ولي العهد الرؤيه لا لن
نواجه اي اشكاليه او او اي مصائب كل مشكله
احنا بهذا الدعم لا محدود لكل القطاعات في
البلد همم
مهمتين النقطه الاولى
همم شكرا خاص
يا سمو امير قطر وااا لاخي ناصر الخليفي
اللي بنو فريق ايضا همم مثل البريد باريس
سان جيرمان همم اعتقد الذي ستكون همم نقطه
مفصليه همم في شعبيه ما قبل المباراه وما
بعد المباراه في الشرق الاوسط انا كان
الان في تواصل مع اخوي ناصر الخليفي ومع
المسؤولين تاريخ سان جيرمان بدنا طلبات
التيشرتات همم لباريس سان جيرمان ثلاثه
اجبال يعني طلبنا الان ثلاثه اجباري كميه
التي طلبناها وانا اعتقد ان سنطلب المزيد
شكرا جزيلا لتواجدك معنا الليله رغم ضغوط
ورغم اقفالك لكل خطوتك بسبب الحرج اللي
قلته
في نقطه في نقطه هنا في نقطه مهمه
بتال لا يعطيكم معلومات غلط مباراه من
الاساس يستعد الملك فهد
الى صوتك
بالاساس تم اختيار استاد الملك فهد شكرا
جزيلا لك معالي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ
رئيس هيئه الترفيه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه